thank you to both rocket money and
hellofresh for sponsoring this video
more on them after the reaction
[Music]
people citizens of the
reacher Nation
Oh did it we are here today to kickoff
Reacher season 2 episode one John how
pumped are you it would be a reach to
say I'm not jacked about this G that's
some Allen tck that's
right my bad I'm on the tck path you
know he's got some buff the citizens
please go ahead leave a like on this
video that would mean a lot also
subscribe click the notification Bell to
get notified when our reaction for
episode 2 is up on the channel if you
didn't catch or Reacher reactions for
season 1 they are of course here thank
you to prepper for helping us edit down
these highlights and as usual a full
length Reaction watch along where you
sync up with your own copy of Reacher
with us as available for super sex Rex
over at our patreon page and over there
John and I cover several things
exclusively with highlights and watch
Longs included any who John you're ready
so ready let's do this let's do
[Music]
it ooh cat skills huh I would love to go
there I'm a Catman I'm a
Catman I'm a
cat damn I didn't even see a Traer for
this I have no idea what we're store for
yeah what's the setting I mean I guess
we're gonna be in New York
but wo whoa that is a
body whoa is he just thrown out oh he
was thrown out ain't no
shoot
jeez is that Jack that's Jack it's Jack
sleeper flat
Reacher Jack Jack for a
second oo they didn't catch the name of
that title I know they they just assume
we pause
everything Arkansas hey it's a c after
going cat skill we're going to cat
luck what am I supposed to do with these
what him and sell them oh thft you
buying anything Jack bearder jeans
t-shirt jacket socks boxers God he is
massive now I know he got fat yes he let
himself go what a fat ass fat
reer
$222 11 yeah Doug was supposed to take
that down a few days ago if you knew
they were supposed to come down why
didn't you do it cuz it's Doug's job and
this is now false advertising and I can
beat the out of you
oh thil sorry I have to make another
withdrawal oh who gave you that Shiner
well hit her Jack she's taking
forever yeah or at least beat up the
vending machine vending machine the ATM
I'm
sorry it's a money vending machine you
know don't turn around I can help you
that minivan on my left that yours oh oh
oh she's kidnapped you've been carjacked
right
ah yes my child is in the back seat that
is a hell of a shot damn yeah stay
here this won't take long oh Jack
Reacher has the best save the cat
moments your mom better hurry the up kid
this is going to go bad for both one
shot yeah what was
that
oh
yes just snapped his rib cage up the
middle now take your shirt off
yeah
wow hi want to see your mom it's okay
you want to see your mom go in the bank
call the cops give them these who are
you someone who prefers not getting
involved okay who's going to pay for my
window I would have at least taken some
money from her
yes the negatives did he get like a fat
deposit Maybe
here's 30 need a new jacket what's wrong
with the one you just bought it has
blood on
it can I use your phone I just got a
message from a friend via the ATM I
think you got like a fat deposit I got
your message 1110th 10:30 at a stress
call that is a fat deposit
yeah this is just message money we set
aside for sending messages Tammy Kates
let me guess bank teller Dino waitress
drift shop cashier
Calvin France was murdered I'll let you
know when I land uhoh these damn
personal connections of people getting
murdered what if he didn't go to the ATM
I
know what other way would the message
have
gotten flashback Jack hello sir just
Reacher I didn't tell you to bring
anything just some office supplies in
case there was any startup paperwork
needed to be done I hate paperwork oh
last season Mentor killed this season
pupil ooh mentees killed what exactly am
I doing here saw you a few weeks ago buy
your barracks stopped a couple soldiers
and beating the hell out of each other
over a stolen care package from home
good man nice cookie in the Box actually
one cookie yeah even dumber bottom line
you negotiated a fair settlement cracked
a few jokes de-escalated the conflict
got a decent head on you you remind me
of
me yes perfect guitar music cute what
the hell kind of unit did major Reacher
put together here huh we got a bean
counter from accounting services ouch
gas jockey from bulk fuel we got Dave
Matthews Grandpa Moses and uh couple of
guys from uh where youall from senior
requisitions right we got
names Sanchez Norco and who are you
besides the guy who talks too much David
Odon oh I've got a rule plans go to hell
soon as first shots been fired so your
first shot better be your best shot
I'm the only non-marine to win the USMC
thousand yard Invitational and I still
know Lowry gives us our best first shot
you think this unit's going to come
under a lot of fire maybe then why'd you
grab a bunch of people with no police
experience major Reacher
Reacher why does any like to be called
major cuz he's not a rank guy none of
that matters out there Army wanted a
unit for particularly complex matters
when they arose to do that I need
special investigators if we're so
special why do they stick Us in this
dump a few years ago Uncle Sam made an
auction bid for some some land down the
road entered the address backwards
became the proud owners of this building
in the contents of the now defunct
Callahan Insurance Agency is that a real
thing that that must have happened
sometime yeah it sounds like straighten
up these boxes move these old tanker DS
in the middle of the
room got really preoccupied with it does
this work this is Jack's add kicking in
go backwards you want me to go backwards
I'm going backwards go backward damn by
season 3 Allen rich and just going to be
like a tiny head poking out of massive
shoulder muscle it's going to be that
guy from hero Academia I could use a
beer there got to be a beer pun for Jack
Reacher Jack
Yorker yor creature thanks for ordering
still steam coming off the cup track the
plane online so I landed early you don't
check bags and I adjusted for traffic
had the coffee poured 90 seconds ago
it's my Fifth Fifth cup though try to
time it right
everything been a minute since Mar been
2 years 7 months 19 days yeah so France
I'm missing after leaving this home in
Brooklyn about a week or so ago body was
found in the Catskill Mountains well
Force up there is like 20 cops NYPD is
taking the leap how'd you find out got a
call from Angela I watch the prog of the
episode fr's Widow fron was married yeah
fun wedding Fran's wife France's Lover
he had a son too life moves on when
you're away big fell France had a FR
line and a fraternal child your messages
in the days before his disappearance
said he wanted to bounce some stuff off
me about a case who was chasing down
woof I kep meaning to get back to him
but before I could andela reached out
and told me he'd be murdered it's not
your fault don't do that it wasn't just
murdered he was tortured got a mucus in
his stomach
dehydrated checked out of a plane an
airplane has a stall speed of what 80
mph it would have shoved him out of the
do's playe horizontally into the
slipstream he'd bang into the wing or
tail there'd be Perry morm injuries than
there aren't who was thrown from a
helicopter sure yeah
dumbass ENT full of free histamines
massive pain reaction that's why Ferris
oxide powder was found in his pants
fabric he was hit with a rusty iron bar
in the pants he was tortured through the
revenge or information when they were
done with him they dumped him from the
sky to avoid ballistics wow he was
calling you for help he may have been
trying to get in touch with the rest of
the unit probably failed I called
odonnell Dixon Sanchez and Rosco I got
to say the background actors are like
exceptional I've been looking at them
the whole
time New York afternoon in a coffee
show what about low killed 2 years ago
in a car accident in Montana no one told
me no phone no address you could have
sent me an emergency ATM message like
today it wasn't really an emergency huh
it was the moment the pickup hit Larry
and be honest would you really have
traveled all the way to Montana from
Texas or Maine or wherever you were at
the time just to look at a body in a box
no ouch the thought that counts so I'll
ask
again next steps let's go see Fran's
Widow yeah like like this guy wouldn't
finish the sandwich get to go box bro
like he would have just eat it on the go
get the fries for a carbo load this
guy's like
full this is the diet I take to maintain
this
physique three bites I'm good for the
day
uhoh she just met up with the big one
let's pronounced bigan odonnell this is
Reacher with another 1030 NE and I are
staying at the veil hotel in Brooklyn
get off your ass and call us back
receptionist at Dixon's office says she
can't say where Dixon is or when she'll
return probably an undercover job yeah
maybe they're all in trouble too
someone's picking them off one by
one this show just got amazing I'd like
a banana I'd like a banana I was going
to say this isn't The Wiggles is is is
it sorry it took me so long to disengage
it's just hard to get my sister off the
phone she calls every hour my own
personal suicide watch no sorry that was
uh morbid I should have said that after
what you've been through you can say
whatever you want reel it in lady yeah
we don't want your life story can't
believe how much your son looks like
franie I called him franzy too oh I know
he loved me and Mikey more than anything
but from the way he talked I don't think
he ever had any more fun than his years
spent with the 1110th yeah he hated
being a
dead the real war was at
home
I was away with Mikey and Provo helping
my sister with our mom early onset
dementia golly I tried Calvin for a few
days and no return calls it's not like
him so I started to worry called NYPD
they just said he could have been out on
a Case cuz he was a
pi or maybe he was out partying because
his wife and kid were out of town wow do
you think that's what he was doing out
partying with the wrong crowd tell him
to stay in school I came back early to
find our home ransacked nothing was
taken were you aware of any cases France
may have been working on he never
brought work home when he was here he
wanted to be 100% present for me what a
good guy seems like her life was a
living hell but she had a great
husband yeah the most baggage with
family but my hobby were any other
members of the 110th working with him I
don't know maybe there's something in
his office there you go a sign on the
door is Three Rivers Consulting and
Associates it's 103 flat Bush what
franzy always told me was the special
investigators weren't any ochre but cops
you do not mess with the special
investigators o spooky creepy child what
are you drawing kid yeah what scribbly
demonic image if you conjured over
there I'm pretty sure that black sedan
halfway down the street was outside the
diner too there's a black sedan on never
Street in
America yeah but this is different punch
the window Jack come
on no the neth checking in under the
name Sarah Connor and uh paying for an
adjoining room using the name staring
Castro must be for the Hulk staring
Castro played for the Yankees Robert
Patrick hey did you know he was in this
no idea perfect though and who's Sarah
Conor just keep an eye on that hotel and
they said Sarah Conor yeah oh my God and
he played Sarah Connor yes get it I yeah
oh my God I can't believe they really
got her very modest for a guy with Wall
Street business close to home so we can
spend more time with his family exact
kind of place fronie would choose checks
out no and they left pissed they were
looking for anything behind this glass
window but they put that phone through
it that's an act of frustration by
someone who didn't find what they wanted
he hey good psychological profiling
Sherlock Reacher seems like
yesterday a partying with
us you're supposed to protect him
jack
ke yeah what do you see you have to put
it in a place that was very secure but
readily available somewhere in plain
sight that we see every day but a place
no one would suspect so it's a place
that's readily available that we entrust
every day with very important items a
door knob this is a mailbox
key oh I ever tell you you're smart
Ney not not nearly enough not nearly
enough I don't want to watch a show
political messages about why post
offices still exist in the era of Amazon
yeah yeah come on big post office paid
for the show Prime video doeser
show 10,000 combinations if it's a four
number code oh he can figure it out hey
get some passwords we have to come back
tomorrow so what do we do now I figured
out the password yeah I mean I'm
expecting that wholeheartedly I'm like
he would do it this way and it would
lead him to these numbers if you let me
win I'm going to be pissed I don't let
you win I pce myself waffle crisp not in
your professional life rental cars a
Range Rover killer hotel rooms sent me
airfare like it was nothing you're doing
well this feels like a fantasy clearly
not pacing yourself in your professional
life but the term wonderin has been
tossed around the office two promotions
in the past two years
hey it's not just about the money feels
good I just take the money yeah I don't
need the money see with anyone else no
did you talk to anyone at the
game you think about going to margrave
during the game more lonely than ever
when you went out to get gas I tried
everyone again radio silence you should
try the phone next time that's weird
they all responded in the group chat
we I've been talking to everyone for
hours instead of leaving a voicemail
there's someone to actually talk to
right because we just established how
much you like talking to people
up gab Reacher it was always obvious you
guys had a think for each other did you
ever sleep together or chat Reacher no
wouldn't have been appropriate you were
the same rank I ran the team oh so look
at you you work out so much because you
got testosterone spreading throughout
your entire system this is your entire
essence of being night Neely night
Reacher oh
that was a really cool transition I'm
going to get a men's room door for my
bedroom flashing
back so whenever we're in the present
day there's kind of a blue lighting and
then whenever we're in the past it's a
green lighting if you don't mind me
asking who directed you to feel this
team S I do mind you calling me sir
you're not supposed to be drinking in
uniform uh oh we're not drinking we were
drinking then you interrupted us it's
the Army do any of us really belong here
ouch some kind of smart guy
smarter than
you people leave me and my pals alone I
leave them alone they don't I don't I
thought his rule was plants go to hell
when the first shots
fir there's a lot of rules for different
situ finish my beer and I'll be on my
way okay sir how about you be quiet your
adult's talking wow dude man what is
your beef I'm not understanding some of
this uh hostility yeah what's going on
here I'm providing you an opening
because I promise my mother I'd give
dumb guys like you a chance to walk
away we got
12 oh you got nine so it's a warm-up
round for reach yeah well that's a shame
you were at least three short
yep
Boogie steps right
through oh my God don't give us and
that's how they bond it as a unit yeah
that's how they become a single organism
[Music]
he hired all those guys yeah hey list
well let's just kick your asses for one
night and then we'll bring so much
business to your bar I promise I need
these people to work together shouldn't
have been at the officer's Club I know
and why get into a fight over it he did
n nicely
a you and I are gonna be Pals we reach
her you're big softy you already are da
you're going to be my series regular
tonight the boys of the 91st learned a
very important lesson that you do not
mess with the special
investigators you do not with the
special investigators you tell your
future children this yes you knew that
was going to happen tonight I knew the
91st like to drink on Thursday nights
and that they're sticklers for the rules
and that they're
I know they can all work
together get yourself a common eny
photo op to commemorate our first date
as a unit you fire how would I just take
it this is the photo
dude my God it's all coming together
okay guys 4 seconds oh take it easy on
your
osteoporosis kiss my ass Young
Blood kiss my
osteoporosis after I take a leak you're
about to get a little taste of Crocodile
Rock I only know Elton John hey Reacher
they talked me from the helicopter
Reacher whoa what are you going to do
about it oh damn flashback so he saw
that in the yes he had a premonition it
was planted there like a memory but it
was really a premonition but he wasn't
able to get lock it until right now
reason for your visit Mr Mount I'm here
to sightsee Universal Studios Walk of
Fame man's Chinese you I'm bit of an old
Hollywood fanatic anything to declare I
have nothing to declare
oh blue
mask took 12 takes for him to get that
right yeah back to one back to K just
throw it walk up to it like a normal
human being you got to get the pages to
Splash when they go
in what buddy wow he's so badass he does
at the airport doesn't even wait to get
to a place more discreet than this can't
have anyone catch me with his passport
I'm the way out of the airport where
everyone has a
passport Angela has no idea which PO Box
belonged to Calvin and the post office
won't give her that information until
the estate's been settled because the
box was in his company's name right
right right of course we can't just go
in there and start trying boxes like 89%
of the world FRS is right-handed so he'
probably ask for a box on the right when
you enter he gets public records sent to
him surveillance photos so he's going to
need one of the big boxes I'll start
with him I just need a distraction okay
okay just going to get naked yes you
know now he's distracted whoa
I can't focus on the job cuz they're
naked NE I am a hardcore Fatalis and I
have been fully a flutter about this new
batch of stamps that were recently
issued yep desert flowers uh state birds
and the world of anime all of them uh
there's at least two dozen of these uh
cartoons if you're not familiar with
anime I believe it's
Japanese God is making me want to go get
some novelty stamps States oh je excuse
me excuse me can I get to my
box is that your key yeah I just can't
remember which box is mine sir this man
is using a key that isn't his what are
you the male
police all good here no sir I'm going to
need some ID that ties you to that box
you know what I'll take all of them how
about that here we go no problem just
got my box is confused Jesus I bet that
old lady is the big villain of the
show hiding in plain
sight my laptop has a different port I
got to go pick up an adapter do me a
favor water up aide on one of those
phone app things oh I need to borrow
your car you know France was killed over
this hard drive and now you want to go
get a gun what do I look like mac
Reacher first I need to go to church
like any church is he just actually
going to church no he knows he's got to
know a priest run away
I'm looking for my cousin he has a
really bad drug problem and a family
friend said they saw him living on the
street around here I'm sorry to hear
that well thank you I promised Myan I
wouldn't come back home without her son
maybe the church has a support group or
something and through that maybe you'd
have some idea where Jimmy was scoring
Jimmy almost everyone who comes into our
outreach program gets their fix from the
same place Dumont just east of
Rockaway but you got to have a death
wish to walk in there alone son I'll be
fine father I have righteousness on my
side sure you got the Lord at your back
you that SM this ain't no furniture
warehouse man I don't do no
credit hey I'd like to buy some drugs
this is time to clean up the streets
yeah
buddy crazy
mother shaking that ass
ouch cocaine oxy MTH full service
dealer
oh don't mind
me I'll be taking this more variety in
the music choices this season yeah I'm
liking the needle
drops for the Outreach
progr
Dizzle he's like I can finally go buy
the drug I want
yes always felt so conflicted about
taking it from the offering tray but now
everyone's always talking about how good
the trucks are right around the corner I
don't get to try any of that help
yourself six figure instruments in the
front there's a completely different
crime happening in Los Angeles it can
shine a lighthouse on them man water
marks are flawless no one will really
know who you are get me a lighthouse and
we'll figure that out but you know whoa
dang what a dangerous profession just
getting back yeah had to go to three
stores to get what I needed you got
everything I needed in one place I know
I know which one had what you
needed there's chocolate on my
pillow and all the sheets
[Music]
are nah n wasn't quick
enough they didn't find what they was
looking for did they there's the sign of
[Music]
frustration hey it's your boy see you're
still using brass knuckles no more
switchblade look
down
oo hey
odonald I love that Trope cuz I'm like
he could still shoot you and he wouldn't
get stabbed at the
CR yeah it's a good distraction but also
a guy like re I can't shoot him he'll
definitely stab me on the crot if I
shoot
him no cell phones no devices no TVs my
screens more greens bars Till by the
third day my devil children want to kill
each other the question is is he a
traitor definitely look at him
snap my toothbrush in
half now I own
nothing that was great delivery it's
okay pretty pissed about this whole
fronzi thing kind of love that kid so
who we killing over
it it's kind of like Jeremy rener from
the town oh password protected hate
guess and passwords about to hate it
more F set it up so we get three guesses
in 2 minutes or the drives a race wow
passwords come from deep down what was
Fran's thing what was he known for just
smash the keyboard and see
whatever yeah Pittsburgh Pirates
Steelers that that sandwich place where
they put the fries on
brothers that was it yeah but not
Pittsburgh in and of itself it was his
loyalty to it still led the 1110th after
all these years taught his kid our
slogan what's his kid's birthday loyalty
is a byproduct where does it come from
hero worship France respected someone he
couldn't be dissuaded got to be a sports
guy Davis was the greatest musician ever
France was loyal to what he respected
that's it Roberto
Clemente about Willie starel did Willie
starel die in a plane crash Deliverance
supplies to earthquake victims it's
Clemente no it isn't who would use a
device like this did he put like a
number or a character who did fron
respect more than anyone any ball player
any artist who did he heo worship a the
kid started cutting his hair like you
talking like you following you around he
wanted to be you reach started eating 12
chickens a day the doctor said you got
to stop working
out it's too much for a skeleton to
handle a oh wow don't go get in a big
head you know his head's way too small
for that big relatively speaking he
probably should even it out you're
booked for your flight to Denver enjoy
your trip thank you I certainly will
damn this guy's going everywhere I like
to go yeah
man Andrew
McBride Andrew McBride Alan Mason
Alejandra Mendes Alexander mopis just a
list of names all starting with the
initials am all aliases you keep the
same initials so your signature never
has to change just an A&M with a
squiggle after it no matter which
pseudonym you're using damn good idea
really
smart well whatever this is it was
enough to get bronze killed your room's
trashed and God knows whatever else we
don't know about these guys aren't shy
about getting aggressive this guy's one
cigarette away from being Constantine
none of on10th are reachable reachable
we send a Christmas card to Swan every
year think he lives in Queens now I'll
have Lily check our holiday mailer list
you really are
domesticated I didn't get a holiday
mailer casting is well done I just I
realized in this very moment like oh I
really believe the history between
Reacher and this other guy
yeah what happens when reer gets a whole
team you smell that that's a
body I'll take the
[Music]
upstairs someone going to be nailed to a
wall with their nuts missing
again
o ooh caller says Maisy call is a dog oh
my God take the toilet B dry whoa Swan
would never let a dog die of thirst only
way he doesn't come home is if he
couldn't come home like the first season
this is the house of that guy who wasn't
watering his dog oh
yeah what are you thinking I'm thinking
there's someone hellbent on taking out
the special investigators but you don't
mess with them and they're coming after
us
good
let's go let's
go hell yeah damn dog I think we should
just read the Wikipedia and what happens
in the book and then make predictions
yeah I think you know what I think going
to go on limb here I think the person
responsible at the end of the day is
going to be a character we haven't met
yet he just is so buff many of you guys
know most of my days are a couple of
hours of filming and then most of the
time it's dedicated to like editing and
a bunch of other computer work often
accumulating to like 10 to 12 hours a
day and on top of that comfort food is
like my life's biggest Vice but as many
of you also know working out and getting
healthier has been a massive component
for me this year in particular so in
this Whirlwind I have found myself a
perfect Ally for quick healthy meals
America's number one meal kit a meal kit
that I have subscribed to prior to ever
agreeing and working with them so yes
this is a genuine testimony and that is
of course for hello fresh and hellofresh
is in just about ease about bringing
health and flavor to your doorstep in
this holiday season forget about the
stress of planning meals for your
healthc conscious friends friends like
me who will breede down the back of your
neck being like I can't eat that that's
unhealthy so with hello fresh I'm
looking forward to hosting holiday
dinners that are not only delicious but
also cater to Healthy Lifestyles best
part the variety it is incredible I'm
pescatarian so they have these delicious
meals just like djon onion crunch salmon
over lemon broccoli spaghetti and from
one more plant-based days the vegan
Maple carrot power bowls they aren't
just meals they're culinary Adventures I
learned the word culinary during a long
day the last thing I want to do is spend
a while cooking and that's where helloof
Fresh's 15-Minute Meals are a lifesaver
they're quick nutritious and Oho tasty
perfect for my non-stop lifestyle so why
not join me in making this holiday
season both health conscious and
delicious with hellofresh with over 45
recipes and seasonal add-ons to choose
from every week there's always something
new to try and here's something to cheer
about go to hellofresh.com reject free
and use code reject free for free
breakfast for life is that accurate that
sounds way too good to be true there's
no way that can be true go to
hellofresh.com reex free and use code
reject free for free breakfast for Life
One breakfast item per box as long as
your subscription is active tag your
hellofresh creations with # hellofresh
piic and @ hellofresh and let's cook up
some fun and healthiness reject Nation
remember it's America's number one meal
kit hey reject Nation you know running
real rejects is an incredible journey is
something I am truly grateful for but I
got to be real with you for one second
here managing the business side
especially taxes to put it lightly is
incredibly overwhelming it's like
navigating a maze without a map and
that's where our sponsor rocket money
comes in a sponsor when approached I was
so excited to work with because I kid
you not just last month I started using
rocket money cuz I needed to sort out
this financial puzzle and honestly it's
been quite eye openening not just for
taxes but boy oh boy that whole cliche
of this app is true I discovered apps
and subscriptions I have been paying for
that I had not used in ages it is like
finding out you've been leaving lights
on in a room that you never use so yes
rocket money isn't just another app it's
like a freaking Financial Guardian Angel
it finds and cancels those forgotten
subscriptions monitors your spending and
even battles to lower your bills thank
God it's as if they're personally
invested in saving your hard-earned
money like I try I really try to be on
top of my expenses rocket money they
show me blind spots with a simple tab I
can cancel unnecessary subscriptions
they even handle the hassle of
negotiating with customer services a
relief my goodness to put it into
perspective rocket money has helped over
5 million users save an average of $720
a year that's more than just numbers
it's a piece of mind so I invite you my
fellow rejects in taking control of your
finances so go ahead visit rocket
money.com rejects once again that's
rocket
money.com rejects let's save together
money.com rejects I really do stand by
this app thank you for partnering with
us yeah so I know there's other episodes
out for this but let's talk about this
John what did you think about our return
to Reacher it's good to be back in
Reacher
territory in a new uh setting and
whatnot I I am looking forward to to how
the setting uh it's again we've started
off in New York it seems like there's at
least a potential that we might stay
there in the first season we were so
immersed in the atmosphere of margrave
and I hope that we can get you know more
of just that unique atmosphere again um
but yeah I don't know it's just great to
be back in and among the characters of
this world it's a lot of setup and stuff
like that we're just meeting the key
players and getting the lay of the land
yeah um so you know I mean I I feel like
this is a good starting point for this
season I'm not like oh my God this is
among the top episodes of Jack Reacher
but uh but I'm thrilled you know this
gave me a lot of the things I would hope
for upon re-entry and now I'm just
excited to see how the mystery grows and
and grabs me and pulls me in with the
blend of personal and badassness yeah
yeah I mean I know we're talking about
most people prob just watch the first
they what they releas three yeah um and
most people probably already watching
finish the other two by now um so I'll
keep whatever slight criticisms or
concerns uh tempered because I'm like
well let's just see they released a few
out on top for a reason right yeah uh
but for a premier episode a great just
return for Allen richson again uh love
the guy so much and he uh that
loneliness in the past couple years he
has significantly buffed up compared to
Jack reach or never go back that's
sophomore entry in Tom Cruz entry um
it's it was it's fun because in that
movie they had the whole he walks up to
a guy in a car window smashes it yeah
like nobody's business and and they open
with this one this is the sophomore one
but this is way better already than all
of that yes was a terrible movie but I I
loved I love I love the fact that we're
getting him and neie uh neie right you
don't pronounce the G uh him and and
neie partnered up together and just
thinking about how they are evolving
Jack from the first EP first season he's
he's he's kept more at at a distance and
at a mystery and then oh you're
compelled by the personal relationship
between him and his brother and even
though he's kept at arms length you're
like I'm gravitated towards this buff
mysterious Wanderer because clearly he
is feeling the anguish of the loss of
his his brother and now they're keeping
that loss going uh with other brothers
and sisters uh the ones that he served
with together but he was also the leader
of and it's an interesting um
relationship of sorts because while he
whilst he was the
leader he wanted to be seen as an equal
it seems like you know like yeah if I if
I give a command you got to obey the
command however Hees like don't call me
major don't call me sir we are we are
equals here and and trust my judgment
but don't fear my rank and much it seems
like everyone really looked up to him
the one who died is the one who most
wanted to be him is the one who most
looked up to him and last season he
wanted to be so much like his brother
and now he has to it starts off with
avenging the one who uh wanted to be
like him the most and so it's it's cool
like Dove tale of a story so I think I
feel like storytelling Wise It's
appropriate to go down this path and
then to get these flashbacks flushing
out his time in the military fleshing
out his time as a major I think is
really cool there there's a lot of
interesting ingredients that I'm excited
to see how the recipe ultimately Cooks
by the end and uh action violence yeah
all strong stuff I do think that it
would be kind of a a mistake to compare
the um the the first episode of like
because your pilot like you really got
to make a bang and you know uh but then
for a first episode of a season two
where you're airing a few on the same
day you you already have the audience
his faith of like well let's just play
it out you know yeah where like in the
in season one you got to like really got
to hook you on that first episode cuz
that pilot was like near perfect right
yeah and it's got to be like a little
short film almost yeah yeah where
whereas like the so I'm trying to
understand some of the stylistic choices
a little bit better so I'm like okay so
we're in the flashbacks of the military
we're in green it makes sense army
people all right I got it and then we're
in the blue of the New York New York
Vibe all right sweet I get it we in La
we're in that yellow totally so I'm
trying to understand the visual language
a little bit I don't know if it's just
like neat cinematography choices of what
they're doing but you know the music was
something that was so integral to last
season uh of of something that created
such an atmosphere to it and like the
the soundtrack was was completely
intentional and in tune with the
character as well and here I'm trying to
just kind of grasp I don't know if I'm
overthinking it but the shows kind of
made me pay attention to the music
considering what they did in the first
season of like what are these tracks you
know like well do the tracks have any
meaning like how they had in last season
you know it does make me wonder what the
shape of this season is going to be like
just because this episode is more I
guess by comparison to the first season
I thought just overall they demonstrated
a nice balance of like here are some are
like thoughtful character-based scenes
that will tie back around to the theme
or to the mystery or whatever it is and
and and namely among those things they
had that thread of Jack uh and his you
know like cultural anthropological
interest inic music and like come into
this region to learn stuff about such
and such a singer and it's like those
those are character ear marks that I
thought really fun and enjoyable and I
like that this thus far has that same
kind of yeah vibrant uh you know
assembled soundtrack but it does make me
wonder like this felt a little bit more
like an episodic show where the first
season had a a really nice blend of I
mean it's obviously it's a very
serialized mystery um but I don't know
that that one felt it carried itself
almost like a limited series in a way
whereas this one at least just at the
outset this episode felt like more of a
part of like an ongoing Series in a
different way um so yeah it's like it's
not like it's totally different or
anything like that but it's much more at
least at the outset I think kind of
focused in on the plot and these people
and it makes sense because they're so
personal to Jack but it is it does make
me curious because the first season yeah
had so much of he's just meeting all
these new people and that gives it all
this flavor with the mystery and he had
that exchange with the girl in the pawn
shop um but that's the only kind of real
like we're interacting with local flavor
you know have you seen The Equalizer
movies I've seen the first one I think
okay so in the first equalizer movie I
would like and that's kind of the first
season Reacher where so much of you
learning about the characters as the
other characters learning about him like
this guy is Unstoppable killing machine
and he's a hyper genius and who is he
yeah and then and equalizer 2 is when it
gets more introspective you're more from
Reacher you're more from uh Denzel's
perspective in that movie and it becomes
more of a character study of him and the
now you're just you're in on the know of
of who Jack Reacher is in this season so
I kind of think that's what they're
doing here yeah first season he is more
of a mystery so you're looking at him
from the perspective of a lot of these
other characters and then this season
immediately is just kicking off with
we're we're with him and now we're
getting more personal with him we're
seeing what these other relationships
the his friendships are like the
communal experience with Reacher is like
he's getting the team is getting back
together even though they don't want to
get back together for like Reunion yeah
yeah they're getting back together for
uh a very specific cause and and uh it's
going to be rooted in in Vengeance and
there's something linked to their past
of something they've discovered before
whatever yeah so yeah like it's it there
are aspects of this that I that very
much remind me actually of equalizer too
and and uh and I I guess I'm just
waiting to see how the Ensemble fully
flashes out because that was one thing
the pilot did in the last one was they
made every character like really
intriguing right off the toally and and
an overall Aura we here we were cutting
around to like New York Los Angeles and
flashbacks and so there's yeah there's
an established tone that we that I think
just needs a little bit time to fully
settle and breathe and then we will have
a better crisp understanding and focus
of what to zero in on but uh but you
know we got seems like we got a villain
set up with Robert Patrick at least what
it looks like looks like we got a
villain set up with that one dude who's
with passports oh yeah the am guy yeah
yeah and then we have uh I like I like I
I love the actress who plays Neely I
think she's a great actress and I like
the other guy I forget his name already
but I like the other guy yeah he he's I
I can't the show could go either one or
two ways like they're they're teasing
him to be the guy who's like a traitor
or they want you to think he's the
traitor because he seems like he be the
obvious one exactly totally uh but I I I
really have no clue and and uh that's
going to be yeah that's going to be a
big part of the fun and I imagine the
more of the people if we are if there
are more survivors of uh you know the
special investigators out there you know
it'll only be more and more interesting
I hope to a get to know them see what
they reveal about Reacher and B I don't
know I mean it if we do meet more of him
it could be any one of them you know
involved somehow CU to your point it
does feel a little bit more
straightforward yeah and not as much of
the unique voice and flavor yeah this
feels a little bit more like oh what I
imagined a Jack Reacher show would be
like yeah when I was told there' be a
show yeah the first season and then we
watched it I was like so much better
than I thought yeah this is good but
it's not but uh there is a special
unique kind of voice it transcends being
an investigative procedural show by
having such a great flare for tone
atmosphere and characters yeah and I can
see all the pieces of that here but yeah
I think it is partly because we are
going so many places in this first
episode and because we do already know
Jack uh at least you know to a a fair
enough extent yeah I could see how maybe
it'll take a minute hopefully maybe by
episode two even just to kind of just to
get that sensibility back because
because it does excite me to be like
okay so we did that with Mar gev and we
really immersed in that environment
what's it going to be like to do that in
New York well yeah I mean New York and
La that's kind of it's just general
popul is Metropolis yeah yeah yeah so
it's like how is that how are we going
to get that more unique we're small town
it's it's intimate you know yeah there's
yeah there's that natural sense of
atmosphere and personality just by being
there you know yeah so much stuff takes
place in metropolitan cities and uh this
whole review can be rendered pointless
why but that's that's the thing is when
you if this was like the only one they
released we could probably talk for
longer yeah no but excited I'm going to
cut us short because I'm like there's
already another episode it so let's just
see if anything we saying is anything we
have to even be
concerned I'm excited regardless yeah
guys what you think about the episode
leave your thoughts down below uh think
you all been support us on
patreon pick a name any I'm feeling who
am I feeling today I'm feeling Ricardo
Martinez Ricardo Martinez you know what
you're getting for Christmas this year
you are going to get a hot air balloon
that's right my friend a hot air balloon
at your disposal because you did great
things for our country
and now you got to get the hell out of
here get out Dodge let's face it man
your service here done it's only getting
worse for it's getting worse it's
getting disgusting and it's time for you
to find a better place to live that'll
make you feel a lot more merry at this
time of year I'm thinking I I don't know
why just off the top of my head Mexico
sure Puerto Rico uh Brazil uh
Peru downtown LA
Chinatown Glendale the
valley o there's so many weener po Loco
I was doing Spanish oh hey sorry take it
back did not pick up on the joke did you
I was doing satirical racism I mean Del
Taco Cal racism is a trademark of my
humor of course and obliviousness is a
trademark of mine you just took it in a
completely different direction
yeah
Ricardo you can travel anywhere in this
hot balloon it doesn't a weer nals man
you can go anywhere you want a hot air
balloon is an anti- parachute so jump
into life man yeah and then you're going
to crash into a
sleigh and guess it's going to be there
a freaking Rabbi oh killed Santa and
it's going to create a whole store of
controversy my God and then either
Ricardo or the rabbi has to take over
for being Santa to cover it up and
either version is entertaining whilst
whilst running the
synagogue Yeah Christmas and hanuka are
going to be fused together through the
spirit of uh
capitalism thanks Ricardo you did you
did your country
[Music]
great